my name is Michael Bustamante and I am a
professional soccer player for that I
need a Red Bulls
face side valleys when your body's kind
of at an angle hitting the ball off the
air usually with your laces if you get a
clean good strike it's gonna be like a
drive into the net I usually do it off a
clearance from a corner kick the ball is
hit in your direction and you don't have
time to control there it's a good skill
to hit a one time ball back into the net
it's not the hardest trick but is you
definitely take some skill to get the
end result the marathon is when you're
dribbling or usually a loose ball you
want to get your dominant foot on the
ball and sort of drag it back you're
gonna start a 180 motion in which you're
gonna keep your eye on the ball and drag
it with the opposite foot back in the
same direction we're heading this is
usually not a skill that most players
will have in their locker and if it's
done well it looks clean and pretty
impressive a snake move is when the
attacker has the ball his dominant foot
you want to sort of dribble with the
outside of your foot
and very quickly get your foot around
the ball and with the inside of the foot
bring it back to the other side when
doing a snake during a match
you're gonna hope to find yourself in a
1v1 situation with the defender where
you can very quickly fake out the
defender and get a shot he's a pretty
difficult skill to get in your locker
but once you have it and once you can
utilize it in a match and make it come
out right you'll draw a couple of walls
you